une partie des cp mélanger avec les
maternelles des locaux exigus une salle
de motricité indisponible car
transformée en salle de repos ou
regroupement pédagogique intercommunal
l'amour à la joue en un an les effectifs
sont passés de 87 à 103 élèves les
parents d'élèves inquiets occupe donc
depuis lundi matin les locaux de
l'établissement et réclament l'ouverture
d'une nouvelle classe
nous on est inquiet aussi pour pour la
santé des enseignants pour la qualité de
leur travail qui se répercute sur le
travail des enfants et notamment les
plus fragiles c'est toujours là c'est
toujours la même histoire en fait il ya
des élèves en difficulté contrairement à
ce que l'on peut penser même en zone
rurale même en zones montagnardes
du côté des communes aussi on soutient
le mouvement lancé par les parents
d'élèves à lamoura le maire a déjà pensé
à une solution temporaire pour
accueillir une nouvelle classe à la
rentrée
nous on a une salle qui est à
disposition des quelques quelques petits
travaux c'est-à-dire les baisser à faire
mais ça peut se faire pour la rentrée du
mois de septembre ce serait la salle de
l'ancien conseil ou alors comme je me
suis dit si c'était pas possible c'est
de luan algeco panda 1 en attendant de
faire les travaux d'agrandissement vous
voyez les plans à l'heure actuelle
une étude est lancée contacté par
téléphone le rectorat sur lui que la
situation est connue et qu'il traitera
le dossier avec un regard bienveillant
les parents d'élèves quant à eux
occuperont les locaux des deux
établissements jour et nuit jusqu'à
jeudi où il espère qu une réponse du
rectorat